welcome to the second presentation on
functions so let's take off where we
left off before and i still apologize i
i in in retrospect that that whole sal
food example well maybe it was helpful
so i'm going to leave it there let's do
some more problems
and then i think the best thing is to
keep doing problems with you and i think
you'll see the example and and hopefully
you'll actually see that functions are
are kind of fun um let's do some more
problems let's start off with an example
not too different than what we saw
before let's say that
g of x
is equal to
let's say
g of x is equal to
1
if x is even
x is even it's like if
if x is even and it equals 0
if
x is odd
right
and let's say
f of x
is equal to
x
plus
three
plus
three um let's say three of three times
g of x
and let's say
i'm gonna make it really complicated
well actually i'm not gonna make any
more complicated now so let's let's try
some problems so what is let's give an
example what is f
of 5
well it's it's really pretty
straightforward we take this 5 and we
replace it for x
in the in the function x and the
function f
so
f of 5 is equal to 5
plus
3 times g
of 5 right we just literally took this 5
and replace it everywhere where we see
an x if instead of a five i had like a
dog here it would be f of dog would be
equal dog plus three times g of dog not
that that would necessarily make any
sense but you get the idea so f of five
equals five plus three times g of five
well what does that equal so the 5 stays
the same
plus 3 times well what's g of 5
well
if we put 5 here if 5 is even we do 1 if
5 is odd we do 0. well 5 is odd so it's
a 0. so g of 5 is equal to zero so this
is three times zero
so this equals just five right because
three times zero is equal to five
well what would be f of
f of six
well f of 6 would equal 6 plus
3 times
g of 6
right
and once again that equals 6 plus well
this time g of 6 is well 6 is even so 1.
so g of 6 is equal to 1. so this equals
6 plus 3 times 1.
so this equals 6 plus 3
which equals 9.
i think you might be getting the idea
now at first when you see a problem with
a lot of these functions it seems very
confusing but if you just keep taking
what's inside of the
parentheses and replacing that for x and
just keep moving along that way
you make a lot of progress on these
problems
let's try a harder one
let's say i said that f of x
is equal to
x squared
plus 1.
let's say that g of x
is equal to
is equal to
2
x
plus
f
of x minus 3
and h of x
is equal to
5
x
now i'm going to give you a tough
problem
what is
h
of g of x
i don't know what h what is h of g of
let's pick a number let's say three
h of g of three and actually we'll do
examples in the future where we actually
could leave the x there and we'll we'll
solve for it but let's say this
particular example what is h of g of 3
that first you might say wow this is
crazy sal i don't know how to even start
here we just take it step by step what
can we figure out can we figure out what
g of 3 is well sure
we could take the 3
and input it into the function g and see
what it spits out
so let's work on g of 3 first
so g of 3
equals well it's 2 times 3 right we're
just replacing wherever we see an x with
a 3. so it's 2 times 3 so that's 6
plus
f of
what we would just replace the x again
3
minus 3
right
so this g of 3
is equal to 6
plus f of what 3 minus 3 is 0
and now we have to figure out what f of
0 is and we know we have a definition
here for f so we just figure it out f of
0
is equal to well you replace the 0 here
so you get zero squared which is zero
plus one so it's f of zero is one
so you take that and you replace it for
f of zero
so you get g of three
is equal to six
plus one
so g of three
is equal to seven right
and now we know what g of three is equal
to we can substitute that back here
so that's the same thing at we know j of
three is equal to seven so that's the
same thing as h
of seven
and h of seven is just equal to
five times seven it equals thirty-five
so
i think you're probably a little
confused here and i would have been if i
was in your in your shoes but the
important thing is when you first see
this problem you're like well what what
what can i tackle first h of g of three
that seems very confusing but well g of
three can i tackle that sure i have a
definition of what the function g does
when it's given an x or in this case was
given a 3. and that's what we did we
figured out what g of 3 was first
and g of 3 we just substituted the 3 and
we said well that's 6 plus
f of 3 minus 3 right because we just
replaced that x with that 3.
and we just kept solving we figured out
what f of 0 is up here and we got g of 3
equals 7 then we substituted that back
in right here and we got h of 7 is equal
to 35 because it was 5 times 7.
let's do some more problems actually
let's do another example with the same
set of
with the same set of
functions
i don't want to keep confusing you with
new functions let me erase this
as fast as i can
i think i'm getting faster this erasing
business let's see
you can sit and think a little bit about
what we just did while i erase
almost done
let's see oh i don't want to erase the
stuff i already wrote oh no i erased it
well i can rewrite it so just put it in
white
and then i change the pen tool
5 h of x equals to 5x
so let's do another problem
what is
well
we first we want to figure out what h of
10 is right before we can substitute um
well we could do it in the different
ways as we'll see later but we can
figure out what h of 10 is pretty easily
right we take the 10 substitute it in
for x h of 10 is equal to 5 times x in
this case x is 10 so it equals 50.
so we know
h of 10 equals 50.
so we know h of 10 equals 50. so we
substitute that back in here so we say f
of h of 10 is the same thing as f of 50.
and then f of 50 is i think pretty
straightforward at this point you just
take that 50 and replace it back here
well it's 50 squared plus one well 50
squared is 2500 plus one
that equals 2501.
what is
let's see
what is
g
of
h of one
well we take h of one
h of one is five so this is equal to
g of five
and g of five we just replace a five
here so g of five is equal to two times
five
plus f of five minus three right we just
take whatever we saw in x replace it
with a five
well that's equal to two times five is
ten
plus f of five minus three well five
minus three is two
plus f of two
what's f of two
well two squared plus one is five right
f of two is five 2 squared plus 1. so
that equals 10 plus 5
which equals 15.
if you're still confused don't worry i'm
going to about to record some more
problems that'll give you even more
examples of function problems
see you in the next presentation bye